[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  that is incredible  can i see two yeah go there go go go  first we decided to change kai's hair  because i couldn't handle one more time  of her being compared to kinley and just  the battle of the blondes kyah you  crushed it unfortunately  we picked the other blonde girl  i knew that we needed to do something  i just thought anything goes let's just  like do it like what do we have to lose  [Music]  my  [Music]  shoes  [Music]  together watch us  [Music]  come on  [Music]  kaya  it's okay  [Music]  i am  excited  to tell you  that you  are the very very first  [Music]  member of xomg  [Music]  [Music]  this week not only has kaya stepped out  of kenley's shadow she has stepped out  of everyone's shadow she can sing on  stage she can dance on stage she is a  pop star she makes xomg cool right now  you did it  however  i don't want anyone to get comfortable  kaya  are you excited  [Music]  you